so in this video we're going to talk
about hyperthyroidism in reducing some
really big side effects that come with
this condition especially the ones that
relate to the heart so if you have this
condition this is gonna be very very
important even though it's going to be a
very short video very simple very very
important okay when the thyroid is in
hyper mode and it's overworking the
demand for b1 greatly goes up why
because b1 is the spark plug that allows
fuel in the mitochondria in the cellular
factories to be converted to energy and
the thyroid hormones connect to all the
cells especially the mitochondria so we
have this situation where we're burning
up all the b1 and it's the deficiency of
b1 where you get all the heart
complications I mean just look up
beriberi for example and look at how
that b1 deficiency affects the heart
berry-berry is a b1 deficiency so if
some of the symptoms from a
hyperthyroidism would be congestive
heart failure that's a big symptom left
ventricular ejection fraction cardiac
hypertrophy this cells of the heart
actually enlarge dysrhythmias so you
have all sorts of problems with the
rhythm of the heart and b1 deficiencies
were detected in 98% of patients with
heart failure so if you also have a
heart problem b1 is what you need to
take I would recommend the whole complex
not just b1 and I would definitely get a
natural b1 not the synthetics so you
want to get nutritional yeast before
both of these conditions and whether you
have a hyper thyroid problem or even a
heart problem and you will notice a
great improvement just by taking that
simple
vitamin go ahead and try it out and then
comment below I want to know your
feedback
so if you're enjoying this content go
ahead and share it with someone that
could really benefit from it